im Walter Benjamin das ist mir nochmal
so ein Synchro geht so eine schöne
Passage wo eine beschreibt oder
behauptet dass man um 18.40 mit
Schildkröten spazieren also
das Loch im Panzer und den Gassi so
großartig
ich hoffe das ist irgendwie theoretisch
vertragbar mit dem Seile oder so aber
das Bild
machen Bahnhof
[Musik]
heute haben wir das ist Fleisch und
Bossard Schönheit
was zieht eigentlich überhaupt ist
davor viel zu oft läuft man
dazu Sterbliche Weise und es geht immer
irgendwo ganz aber ich glaube der
heutigen Zeit empfindet sich einfach
und mit Parkplatz
weniger und das hätte ich mit dem mit
dem Drucker Gesellschaft
ich bin pleite und hat damit gesprochen
schrecklich oder zum Beispiel beim
Minions
reduzieren und gleich nimmt nicht das
Gefühl
genau
seid das ist paradox oder Aldi
technologische Erfindungen
müssen aber paradoxer wie ist möchte
jetzt einfach viel mehr E-Mails anstatt
weniger Briefe von mir Wäsche dafür mehr
als früher
Beschleunigung ist das Merkmal von der
Moderne und ich meinte einerseits etwas
Gefühl von mir hängt so also das Gefühlt
wenig Zeit aber auch Zyklus also wie
lang lebst du ein Ort wie lange bist mit
einer Partnerin zusammen wie lange hat
Job das sind alle die Frequenzen und
alle kürzer wurden
gemacht Punkt fertig und bezieht
der technologische Fortschritt ist
paradoxer wie es ein Grund dafür aber es
gibt noch mehr Wettbewerb besteht die
wichtige Grund weil die anderen
schneller rennen und du meine
kapitalistisches System bist wo besser
muss die andere und schneller und
effizienter du musst schon mit drin das
schaut plötzlich so offen und der geht
immer so eine weitere spekulative Grund
dafür für die Beschleunigung für die
aber gar nicht ohne interessant nämlich
dass das zirkularisiert also dass man
immer alles sehen sieht oder nicht
Druck glauben sondern nur die 80 Jahren
da und alles mit Betrieb sondern Angst
nicht fertig waren
mache wenn man das vornehmen und das ist
natürlich sehr spekulativ aber
vielleicht macht es gleich ein bisschen
so dass Gott tot ist und dass es
endgültig fertig ist verlieren
Walter Benjamin das ist mir nochmal so
ein Synchro geht so eine schöne Passage
wo man beschreibt oder behauptet dass
man um 18.4 mit Schildkröten spazieren
also
natürlich dass Du Dich anpassen die
Person wo langsam läuft
optimiert hat also chill gerade
so großartig das ist so cool und ich
werde das irgendeiner machen mit der
Schildkröte ich hoffe dass ich irgendwie
aber das
Bildung
[Musik]
doch ich finde es oft sehr absurd weil
am Schluss vom Leben zurück für was hat
sich gelohnt denn all die hektische
Moment wo du eigentlich auch nur
funktionierst und planen schon gar nicht
im Moment selber bist
vieles von dem finde ich schlafwirkungen
das heißt wenn du irgendeinen Job hast
wo du dich überhaupt identifiziert und
schlechte Stunden
machen
oder halt normal unglaublich viel mehr
Aussehen wahnsinnig attraktiv in
Arbeitsschutz
groß also du verlier Schweiz
und das finde ich interessant das
eigentlich die Geissen von Erfolg
die arrivierten
überhaupt
danke
im Augustinus sportmittelalter gibt's
im Buch konfessiones was ist eigentlich
sieht typisch philosophische Frage
antworten
millionenstoßerkunde dass ich jetzt oder
wo irgendwelche
also zieht besteht eigentlich aus drei
Sachen wo es nicht geht Zukunft geht so
nicht Vergangenheit ist immer schon
verbiegenheit
wunderschön und dann schieben sie eine
Lösung
ja
Objektiv gibt es die vielleicht nicht
aber mehr aus dem danke
mir bisher erwartet was jetzt gerade
du hast noch bisschen im Kopf was ich
jetzt schon gesagt habe der letzte
Melodie oder kirscht du antizipieren
und das jetzt denkt sich so hast du
sozusagen
bis subjektivs ein bisschen was mehr
möchte für Gott oder objektive Welt gibt
und das Finden unglaublich interessanter
Punkt interessant ist
eine reine Form der Anschauung der
Kritik daran
nicht dem Glas zu oder im Wasser oder
der oder einer Schildkröte sondern mehr
lecken zieht auf die Sache wie drauf so
wenn wir ein bisschen erfahren denn Hund
zieht immer wieder zu und das finde ich
eigentlich so der Gedanke und
verstörende finde ich interessant finde
wirklich
genauso wie Räumlichkeit
Boden rühmlich denken
Punkt
die Frage also es gibt also Physiker
werden
natürlich nicht aber das ist so
verwirrend das ist so verwirrend das
können wir einfach gar nicht danke
nur indem man die Brille
Filter wo alles drin muss und darum
können wir die nicht ablecken und dann
können wir gar nicht verstehen
einfach so anhören aber wirklich
verstochene missioniert und das finde
ich
erfüllten
und wenn man sie richtig braucht
dass man sterblich sind so das handbeben
genau
genauso ein wichtiger Schlüssel also
dass das carpe diem oder das einfach
immer meint jetzt sich und deine
verpassen vor lauter planen und sich
entwerfen die Zukunft und ich die
Balance die Balance halten oder aber
gleichzeitig
Leben
[Gelächter]
für Pension mit 40 gehen so und ich
schaffe jetzt einfach sehr viel bis ich
40 bin und dann aber wirklich
selbstbestimmt und befreit gesagt
Mensch aber also ehrlich gesagt
also du hast mit 40 schaffen als
Lagerist da hast noch nicht klar
die letzten Jahren am meisten
begeisterte
nichts tun und ihre Hälfte
[Musik]
also ich würde lieber nett und
er sagt
immer schön
und irgendwann lieber danke schön
und richtet sich wirklich
und schlussendlich muss Kanzlei
ausziehen und sich andere Räumlichkeiten
suchen völlig absurds Buch aber Jenny
das ist eigentlich der zieht souveräne
danke
tollsage
und irgendwie finde ich so als das Buch
hat mich sehr erreicht das nicht zu tun
aber Schildkröte
diese cool
irgendwo mit der Schildkröte spazieren
super
[Musik]
spannend und wenn du mit zum Thema
wissen
kann
über Vergangenheit und Lebenszeit
dann abonniere doch der Kanal danke